je m'appelle julie da chez g prendre
trois ans et j'ai été diagnostiqué
autiste asperger tardivement à l'âge de
27 ans est aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous
parler des spécificités de l'autisme au
féminin j'ai eu un parcours de vie assez
chaotique jusqu'à mes 27 ans j'ai vu
beaucoup de psychologues de psychiatres
de médecins en tout genre etc et aucun
n'a réussi à mettre le doigt sur les
difficultés à poser un mot sur ma
différence simplement parce qu'en france
l'autisme est très mal connue et le
syndrome de la spyker encore plus
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit des femmes
puisque leur autisme s'exprime de façon
beaucoup plus subtil d'où cette errance
diagnostique très longue et en fait mon
cas n'est pas du tout un cas isolé
il est plutôt représentatif de la
plupart les parcours des femmes
d'autistes on dit que pour l'autisme au
sens large y aurait une femme autiste
pour quatre garçons autistes ou pour
l'autisme sans déficience intellectuelle
une femme autiste sur neuf garçon
autiste mais qu'en réalité peut-être
c'est totalement faux et que ça se
trouve dans quelques années on se rendra
compte que c'est une femme autiste pour
un homme autistes c'est juste qu'on
n'arrive pas à les détecter et aller
diagnostiquée alors pour être
diagnostiqué autiste il faut remplir un
certain nombre de critères on parle des
difficultés de communication et les
difficultés sociales
on parle aussi des intérêts spécifiques
donc ça ça désigne les passions dans les
cas les personnes autistes investissent
énormément de temps et d'énergie et dans
lesquels souvent elles deviennent des
expertes et aussi les particularités
sensorielle et on retrouve très souvent
notamment une forte sensibilité au bruit
donc ça ce sont les critères
diagnostiques
mais en fait ces critères diagnostiques
ils ont été établies à partir de l'étude
de cas masculin on s'en rend compte
aujourd'hui et donc forcément on voit
bien qu'il y a là un biais de genre qui
est très important defacto on laisse en
fait de côté toute la population
féminine et les spécificités de
l'autisme au film chez les femmes
l'autisme se manifeste de façon beaucoup
plus subtil elles ont des compétences de
communication qui sont meilleures que
les hommes elles ont moins de
comportements
répétitif et stéréotypé et elles ont des
intérêts spécifiques qui sont plus
socialement acceptable par exemple si un
garçon se prend de passion pour les
plans de métro ce qui va pas manquer de
susciter l'étonnement de son entourage
une petite fille elle elle va se prendre
de passion pour les chevaux donc ça va
être avec la même intensité et la même
ferveur mais comme la nature de
l'intérêt spécifique est différent et
plus socialement acceptable ça va passer
inaperçu au delà de ça ce sont aussi des
personnes qui vont intériorisé leurs
difficultés
donc les femmes elles vont développer
les troubles comme l'anxiété ou la
dépression
là où les petits garçons vont développer
des troubles comme les troubles
obsessionnels compulsifs ou les trouble
oppositionnel qui sont plus visibles et
qui là encore vous mettre la puce à
l'oreille de l'entourage tout ça a lié
au fait que effectivement depuis toute
petite elle ont pris soin d'adopter la
stratégie du caméléon d'observer
d'imiter leurs pairs etc
ça fait d'elles des personnes autistes
qui à l'âge adulte sont sont invisibles
et j'espère qu'on va parler de plus en
plus du cas des femmes parce que quand
on évoque l' autisme et d'ailleurs même
dans les médias on le voit bien on pense
tout de suite à un homme et on se dit
pas que ça concerne aussi des femmes
donc c'est très important qu'on parle
d'elle qu'on mettre en lumière les
difficultés et qu'on met en lumière les
difficultés qu'elle rencontre et qu'on
les accompagne en fait surtout